I was reading a Gartland study the other
day on marital stability
Gottman has done some really good
analysis of couple's behavior he has set
up a lab that's basically a bed and
breakfast and he brings couples in there
for a weekend and he wires them up
physiologically and monitors their
reactivity and so what he's he can
predict whether a couples going to
divorce with ninety five ninety four
percent accuracy
it's like impressive so what is he found
he's found two categories of he's
identified two phenomena that are very
much worth knowing the first is that the
couples who are going to get divorced
they come into the bed-and-breakfast and
they speak with each other quite calmly
but it's more walking on eggs call and
while they're speaking with each other
calmly their physiology is like they're
very aroused and so they're sort of
aroused like someone who's facing a
predator so you might think of an
unhappy couple as predator and prey to
each other and so the words are there
mostly to stop predatory activity not to
actually communicate anything it's just
to keep the surface calm so then you
might think well what's under the
surface and what's under the surface so
Freud would say it's what's under the
surface is unconscious and but you can
say well what's under the surface is one
of these hierarchies that's all banged
up and twisted and and and not in
reasonable shape and so people don't
want to open the door to that so but
they do this is a Freudian slip so let's
say this is goes to the second part of
Cartman's observations so the woman goes
over to the window and she says oh look
there's a cardinal outside you know
Cardinals that break red bird they're
kind of cool-looking you know it's kind
of a trivial thing in some sense but by
the same token it's like it's a little
positive thing and you know twenty of
them in a day's good thing okay so then
the partner
husband in this example has a two-by-two
matrix of choices one is who the hell
cares about your stupid burg okay so
that's one the second one is then you go
over and look at the bird right and the
third one is you don't make the contempt
noise but you act it out and the fourth
one is you go over there like a
civilized human being and you know and
that you're interacting with someone
that you care for and you take a look at
the damn bird and you're happy about it
and and that's as truthful and real as
you can manage okay so the option that's
a Freudian slip right because what it
says there's a whole monster underneath
that and the monster is all the
disorganization in this entire structure
it's like the might be we have been
tormenting each other about various
things for the last ten years and none
of them are resolved and I'm not very
happy about you for so many reasons I
can't even remember all of them and I
can't enumerate them right now because
that would take forever and maybe we
would have a huge fight but by the same
token I'm not going to come over there
and make you happy with your stupid bird
and I'm gonna indicate that subtly so
you can't call me a son of a bitch
because I'm just sighing and that's what
I'll say if you do ask me but I'm gonna
load all that up and I'm gonna deliver
it to you and what's going to happen to
you is because you're smart is your
heart rates gonna go way up like you're
being attacked and the reason for that
is you are so what the good couples do
the couples that you know stay together
is they respond to each other's bids he
calls them bids and so if one person
wants to share some little trivial daily
positive thing with the other the other
you know isn't carrying around a bloody
cartload of resentment and is able to
respond to that in a positive way and
that way the general interactions
between the couples stay positive but
that's also because they've worked this
out now you know it's got to be because
they work it out because the couples who
are physiologically reactive to each
other they're
communicating but there's all sorts of
horror underneath the surface and we're
trying to figure out well what is it
that's underneath the surface what's the
structure of the unconscious well that's
the structure of the unconscious and
it's either well structured and
functional and mutually agreed upon and
as explicit as possible or it's this
constantly